[Music]
there's a 31 year old man on probation
in a human trafficking case uh and he is
he's in jail again so he's already on
probation for a human trafficking case
a 31 year old man yeah your ears are
exposed
i just look at here he hears with the
pores
your ears are exposed
it was hard to see what steve was saying
to see what he said yeah
how does stevie wonder do it there well
i was oh i had the biden in my heart so
i was like
i had this this might be a dumb question
and this is completely off topic but was
stevie wonder born without vision
uh i don't know good question right
that's a good question it's pretty cool
ray charles developed that i heard he
lost it when he saw his mom's titties oh
you know i heard that too actually have
you ever seen that video that's like
it's a conspiracy thing that he's not
really blind
he was telling about it really quick
he's like i lived in this building with
stevie wonder and stevie wonder was in
the elevator and he walked in
and then stevie wonder goes what's up
shaq
what's up dude no [ __ ] way maybe he
smelled him he probably smelled him
i'm sure his height you could probably
hear how tall shaq is doing
elevated elevators like
i met stevie wonder did you really
at a music conference was he blind he
was just looking at like um like guitar
or was he looking at things doesn't make
any fun
he wasn't looking at things but he just
said that he was well he was browsing
around
at different booths
he was listening maybe maybe right he
was at a basic sonar
basically yeah he was i don't know what
he was bat noises and [ __ ] he was
walking around okay
at different booths no one was
approaching this guy he was standing
with his bodyguard i think a lot of
people were like ooh let's leave a room
i was like [ __ ] that [ __ ] i'mma get a
[ __ ] picture right so i went up to
him i was like excuse me stevie what the
sir can i get a picture with you and he
turned around he knew exactly where i
was and then he went like yeah and i
gave the [ __ ] camera to his security
guard who was annoying
what's up george zakala it's like you're
watching my [ __ ]
he subscribed to it on youtube yeah so
31 of the human traffickers ah we're
good okay yeah no so yeah he's so he's
already on probation for a human
trafficking case okay now take that out
of your head this he's now in jail for
doing something else
what what that something else is he was
recruiting he's trying to recruit
babysitters
to uh to put diapers on him and treat
him like a baby what that's a thing
that's okay so he's a pedophile but he
also wants to be a kid that's kind of a
trendy kink right now though that baby
[ __ ] thing yeah right wait is it yeah
that's a trending kink i would say i
hope i didn't say something i don't know
if it's trending but i know it's an
existence it's trending in this guy's
head
he's thinking about it he's thinking
about it pancakes yes
yes sir please it's definitely a weird
kink but like you know wait real quick
though uh is that illegal if he's
trying to get babysitters to treat him
like a baby are the babysitter's adults
well due to his past rap sheet i'm sure
it's here i think they're there to
babysit and then it becomes that there's
fetish escorts that do this why is he
hiring real babies because that's even
better i think it's i think it's that he
violated
i think he's violating his probation
by soliciting babysitters to uh to care
for him while he he posed as a young man
with special needs are they teen
babysitters wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait you didn't see the special
needs
you got to peel back the onions slowly
don't you
there's new layers every single time
that's an onion so this guy posed to be
a down syndrome kid yeah with special
special needs special needs did he
specified he was just saying that he
needed yeah so he was duping them
i hope he's a 31 year old that looks 45
because that would be even hilarious
there's no pictures unfortunately so how
did he uh get off the sex trafficking
stuff everyone's getting off with
everything
yeah human trafficking because of covet
like joe said there's a lot of people
who are maybe uh who are going to be
spending more time in prison who are out
on release while they await their trials
so it's a good time to do crime right
now you're saying it's [ __ ] great
no get it out of your system right now
yeah no it's only good for like violent
crimes though yeah because you know the
prosecutors are prosecuting right now
too still not a good time to do like tax
evasion uh
no definitely because biden just hired
yeah
our camp just hired 20 000 more members
to do to the irs
so
it's not a good time to do tax fraud
damn it yeah dude and then we also
defunded the police so it's not a good
it's a good time to do crime it's a good
time to it's a good time to do crime it
seems like good dumb dude to be honest
20 more people in the irs yes
what i voted for
yes
but i also told them that he's ruining
this country big time you can get
probation from like human trafficking
people that's crazy right that's insane
right yeah just a slap on the wrist like
what is that what the [ __ ] is going on
you know yeah i thought my container
only had 13 people in it that's what i'm
saying yeah what's the what's the
maximum that's the question yeah
it's under two dozen officers yeah and
they're like oh probation it's also the
definition of human trafficking could be
like literal trafficking like putting
him in a [ __ ] box and shipping him or
it's like you just have some girl be a
prostitute and give you a cut that's
also human trafficking oh like that's
the same [ __ ] yeah so who knows how do
you know about all this in the trending
kinks huh
he definitely was trying to traffic some
stuff in his diapeys because he wanted
he wanted these babysitters to change
him and swaddle him and cuddle him to be
fair
behind closed doors in a non-illegal way
that sounds really fun right big swaddle
get to be a baby my issue with this guy
is is like white you can't have your
cake and eat it like you can't [ __ ]
want to
dupe these regular babysitters into
making them do all this weird [ __ ] when
you could just hire escorts like right
like why wouldn't you just find one
feels more real probably yeah but that's
right but that's what i mean you can't
have your cake and eat it there's
there's trade-offs to everything you can
have a cake and let it go sexual full
sexual
hate gun sexuality i think the part of
his kink is doing the forbidden thing
yeah and i think it's coercing people
who don't know what's going on he's a
prankster yeah you know a social
experimenter do you think he's gonna get
probation for this [ __ ] too or like what
like where did he violate it so he
should go to jail he's doing it at a
really good time but no one's going to
jail right now so what's happening is
like we're gonna pull we're gonna
violate probation we're gonna put more
probation on your probation yeah exactly
you're gonna have more probation while
you're outside of jail yeah it's like
now you've got two probations they
cancel each other out oh ready to go
you should feel bad but you're free to
go you know what's weird is that this
phenomenon of like
just not prosecuting criminals it's
happening
everywhere
it's a phenomenon it's like it's not
just l.a everyone thinks so like in
hawaii right like um you know there's a
lot of people that are uh doing
what's considered like a non-lethal
crime or like violent crime no i mean
yeah but but it is violent like some of
it is sexually violent like some guys
are going out there groping women all
day and repeatedly and then they don't
they don't grab them up put them in jail
nothing like that and i'm like what the
[ __ ] is happening right now and the same
thing with la like you know people are
breaking into cars whatever whatever
they're not being prosecuted so it's
like oh it's because we want to handle
the big uh bad criminals but there are
big bad criminals that are robbing
people uh at gunpoint but they're still
being released that's why it feels like
crimes against other people fine crimes
against the government
gonna get you do it gonna get you oh
even though [ __ ] the guys that are
getting caught for the whole asian hate
thing like beating up asian grandmas and
stuff they're seeing that they're
they're they're multiple record guys
yeah like they've done violent crimes in
their own
stuff they're out yeah but they're left
out into the streets so it's like what
the [ __ ] man it's not like this is the
first time someone's doing it because
they have mental health problems it's
like they've been having mental health
problems [ __ ] people up this might be
their eighth grandma you know i don't
know yeah yeah all i know is the justice
system's working because they got galen
not for long they got her good not for
long they got on a suicide watch that's
what they got oh you know and they're
gonna get her clients next you guys just
wait and see i promise you got a whole
ever black book so we'll see yeah you
know you know that's gonna be next well
they did release it but uh none of those
people are being prosecuted yet
do you think they will yes of course the
justice justice always wins remember is
that the big guys that everyone's trying
to uh go after or you think they're just
gonna like for example she like that one
chick virginia whatever is not allowed
technically go out to go after epson
anymore because she got paid half a
million and she took it back in the day
virginia go free she's going after uh
prince andrew right now yeah
so also hoping for a multi-million
dollar settlement according there's also
um a possible mistrial because galen's
lawyers are now saying that the jury
spoke you think there's some insider
information that's okay if that goes
down a mistrial because of some sort of
weird ass technicality
and oh that would that would be such an
ironic but an american way for things to
go down all right
that would be so we should all know we
should all find out who that [ __ ]
tattletale jury was like who's the loose
lip jury member that [ __ ] it all up
such a technicality dude i thought we
had a real life batman that could come
and fix things like this i know
you mean that vigilante's just gonna
[ __ ] fools up because yeah
yeah we should guess okay so if you're
in charge of the crime and justice
department right imagine all these dudes
in hawaii just like semi violently
groping women all day what the galan was
the big one you know who are on the on
the [ __ ] book but you got to start
with the small crimes first before you
work your way up how how do we treat
that because incarceration is also an
issue right so like depending on who
you're talking to or for what reason
just [ __ ] throwing everybody in jail
is also not 100
the problem with vigilantism right now
is just that grappling hooks aren't that
good yet they're not they're really not
they're not and it takes a long time
and it's finding the right thing to
shoot at and i hella bought one when i
was young and it didn't work they don't
work yeah you also have to have like
enormous strength i have to install more
like points of but this is like made by
elon musk's style it just goes like this
and just grabs them dude he grabbed me
right now i feel like this is my batman
this is my vigilante yo i'm about to go
with them you have to be attached to
some kind of power source to use that
[ __ ]
this is a recoil system in there you
gotta have hella good grip yeah what
about your grip though i wanted to be a
superhero that just killed all the bad
guys but then i realized we wouldn't
have any world leaders anymore oh nice i
hate nice hot day see what you did there
all of them all of them will be gone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you